welcome to the daily climate show coming
up
the rush for new supplies of fossil
fuels is delusional says the united
nations chief
the risks of relying on those fossil
fuels has been exposed by the ukraine
war the head of the biden
administration's environmental watchdog
tells us
and impacts of the climate crisis record
floods close yellowstone national park
while tens of millions of americans are
warned to stay at home amid record heat
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we track the changes happening to our
world challenge our leaders to come up
with solutions and reports on the impact
the climate crisis is having
and we start today with a warning that
the repercussions of the war in ukraine
are playing out in ways that will be
hugely detrimental to the planets in the
long term the united nations secretary
general speaking at a meeting in austria
said the country is exploiting new
fossil fuel energy resources in response
to a global energy crunch are ignoring
the science on climate change we are
witnessing a historic and dangerous
disconnect
science and citizens are demanding
ambitious and transformative climate
action
meanwhile
many governments are dragging their feet
this inaction has grave consequences
climate disruption is being felt right
now with nearly half of humanity in the
danger zone
and the founder of the austrian world
summit arnold schwarzenegger was
scathing in his criticism of countries
for not moving more quickly towards
green energy sources
we owe it to the ukrainian children
growing up in bomb shelters we owe it to
ourselves
we must do whatever it takes to
eliminate our addiction to fossil fuels
we must be part of the solution
not part of the problem
failure is no option here
our science and technology editor joins
me now tom clark so the reality of what
mr schwarzenegger wants and what he gets
is different absolutely and of course if
everything's to do with progress on
climate is that gap between ambition and
reality and one of the realities at the
moment of course is we need to reduce
emissions by about 45 percent in the
coming decade in fact they're projected
to rise by about 14
as economies rebound from the cobit
covered pandemic so the issue we've got
that doesn't even include the conflict
in ukraine and of course that could be
galvanizing action to go for renewables
to pursue greener technologies we're
also seeing lots of economies in the u.s
and across europe scramble for fossil
fuel resources by making investments
there are we baking in commitments to
high emissions for decades to come so a
question i put to michael reagan he's
the new administrator of biden's
environmental protection agency in the
us and i ask him are we in a better
situation now than we were coming out of
the glasgow climate summit
i can say that this uh war has served as
a stark reminder
that we should not be reliant on fossil
fuels and so in the united states over
the past year 80 percent of investment
in new capacity for energy generation
has been wind solar and battery storage
if we had been making investments like
that over the past 10 to 20 years we
would not be subject to the price
volatility that we're seeing now because
of this unprovoked war so i believe it's
a reminder as harsh as it is it's a
reminder that we need to continue to
invest heavily in clean energy and wean
ourselves off of fossil fuel for the
sake of the planet for the sake of
public health but also for the sake of
national security
and what one aspect of that that your
agency i know is is particularly
involved with obviously methane
emissions from u.s um fossil fuel plants
and pipelines etc
the president has committed to a massive
reduction in methane wants the rest of
the world to join him that was announced
at the summit
are you confident you're going to be
able to maybe go to the egypt summit
with some progress to show in terms of
curbing methane emissions in the u.s
because as i understand it they're
actually increasing at the moment
i'm very confident
not only
has the president led with the global
methane pledge
which significant number of countries
have signed on to
but we've proposed the most stringent
methane regulation in united states
history and we should be finalizing that
soon
that is capturing and reducing methane
emissions from both new and existing oil
facilities so i'm very very optimistic
that we are staying the course and that
will leverage technology and leverage
new business models and leverage the
ingenuity uh of you know our private
sector to reduce methane in a way that
will provide significant benefits uh to
not only the planet but to communities
that reside near these facilities
i want to come on to that in a moment
but one question first as i understand
it the supreme court is currently
expected within days maybe
imminently to decide on whether to curb
your agency's powers
to enforce environmental regulations
particularly around emissions from
fossil fuel plants are you worried the
epa is about to be defanged by by
conservative judges
listen we're following the supreme court
cl case very closely and they will make
a decision on
a regulation that focuses directly on
uh
reducing uh emissions from power plants
uh but i've said from day one the
president has a number of tools in his
toolbox and as we look at all of the
regulations uh that govern power plants
we have regulations that look at
traditional air pollutants water
pollutants and coal ash or you know
hazardous waste cleanup we're presenting
all of those regulations at the same
time and companies will take a look at
the suite of regulations and determine
if they want to invest or double down
and invest in the past or if they want
to invest in clean energy solutions for
the future so while the supreme court
case is very important
it's not the only game in town
and before we move on just find it how
much of your
work since taking over has been to undo
a lot of the damage done to the epa by
the previous administration
listen it was uh very tough walking into
this agency and looking at
uh looking at you know old colleagues in
their eyes that i served with prior uh
during my first tour with epa and and
just seeing the damage that was done
over the past four years but you know
the the staff the career staff at epa
are resilient uh they have really hit
the ground running they're excited about
this new administration
we've proposed a number of regulations
that will curb greenhouse gas emissions
as the governor says terminate pollution
protect families protect communities and
so we feel really good we feel really
good about where the agency is today and
we're just going to keep moving forward
you're the first african american to run
the epa how much work does the u.s have
to do to address environmental racism in
your country
yes it's not lost on me that i'm the
first black man to lead this agency and
it's not lost on this administration
just how much work we have to do
to tackle environmental racism
environmental injustice but i can say
that the president has pledged that
environmental justice will be a
centerpiece of this administration
leadership matters he's given us the
ability
to pursue this issue very vigorously and
that's exactly what we're going to do
well let's get to a bit more of today's
climate news now because record floods
and rockslides have forced a rare
closure of yellowstone national park
which spans the u.s states of wyoming
idaho and montana all entries to the
park were closed for the first time
since 1988 after roads were washed away
and bridges damaged torrential rain in
one of the wettest springs in years and
a rush of water from snow melt following
a sharp rise in temperatures combined to
cause the appalling conditions
elsewhere in the u.s more than a hundred
million americans are being warned to
stay indoors if possible as a heatwave
stretches from the southwest to cover
much of the rest of the country the
national weather service says several
temperature records were set in the
western us during the weekend and some
farmers say the heat has caused crops to
spoil
and britain has put the first round of
sites to be used for the storage of
carbon up for bids from potential users
carbon capture and storage or ccs
technology involves capturing the carbon
dioxide emitted from industrial
processes before it hits the atmosphere
and piping it deep underground where it
can be permanently stored now the north
sea transition authority said the
country aims to store 50 million tons of
co2 in this way every year by 2035.
that's all from us today thanks for
watching we'll see you soon bye
[Music]
you